Demons are attacking the home. Very
common is kids watching horror movies.
Children are experience experiencing the
brokenness in the home. Uh the demon of
suicide comes and they gravitate to
anything suicidal
>> or they just gravitate. They just
naturally are attracted to anything that
uh is you know demonic or it feels like
torturous or something like that. So
it's it's because of the brokenness in
the home that triggers that and then the
demons start to bring them towards that
or you know when they're by themselves
they experiment they open doors they
look at all sorts of programs on
television unsupervised
uh and uh they watch it once they might
have been horrified the first time but
then after that they've opened the door
and uh demons are coming in and they're
getting hooked.
>> Welcome back David to the show. I know
last time we talked about spiritual
warfare. A lot of crazy things have
happened and uh it's a topic that we
have talked about a few times. Now we're
seeing a lot more need for this. So
welcome back.
>> Yeah. So you know since the last time I
was here with you guys, a lot of people
have reached out from all over the world
uh and asking for counseling or advice.
And one of the most common things that
I've seen is how demons are attacking
the home. M
>> uh you know and uh there are really kind
of top three uh channels that I'm seeing
and and one is through abuse or where
the parents are talking about divorce
and it's not even divorce yet but
they're talking about divorce. They've
just mentioned the word divorce and
>> that's such a devastating effect to a
young mind and the demons start to play
with that. Uh you know and of course uh
when it ends in divorce that's even more
devastating. uh and then you know
bringing kids to witch doctors in many
parts of the world that seems to be a
common practice especially in
>> the US as well
>> not so much in the US uh it's more of a
Asia thing
>> uh and so parents even Christian parents
when they've seem to have exhausted all
possibilities it's common in certain
cultures uh sorry I take that back in
the US it's much it's common in Native
American culture
>> right
>> and so Native American culture is
similar to some of uh my wife's culture
uh that I mentioned last time where uh
she comes from a tribal group in
Malaysia called kadazans uh and and it's
very common for them to go to the witch
doctor even if you're a Christian. So
bringing kids to witch doctors is also a
common way which kids get possessed or
you know harassed.
>> And what about like the new age that's
coming into the United States?
>> Yes, of course that too.
So that would be classified under the
occult.
>> Um, but I'm talking about like kids are
sick,
>> parents don't know what to do
>> and as a last resort or maybe even as a
next resort, they would just bring them
straight to a witch doctor.
>> We had a couple on our channel from um
the Netherlands and that exact thing
happened. Um there was I think an issue
with the pregnancy maybe or when the or
when the child was really young and they
went to a medium to try and find out um
they hadn't been converted into
Christianity yet at that point so they
didn't see anything wrong with that and
they said we'll try whatever helps but
it opened a door and their daughter had
really um been exposed to seeing the
demonic world around her and you know
they would torture her all throughout
her her 20 years of her upbringing
>> and and the parents were super genuine.
win too. Like they genuinely wanted to
find help, which I'm sure these people
do that as well. So, it's really sad to
see how the devil has a stronghold, but
there was redemption redemption story
there because they did overcome through
Jesus Christ and I'm sure you'll have
some of those to share as well.
>> Yes, I will. Yeah. And then the last one
that I've seen very in common is kids
watching horror movies.
>> Now, we've had a couple people um come
through our ministry that that was their
cup of tea. They watched a lot of horror
movies. Yes. We've had some very
interesting discussions. We haven't
touched much on it on on our shows, but
um but I personal conversations. Yeah,
it's I've heard this many many times.
>> To me, that seems obvious.
>> Like,
>> yeah,
>> just if you don't want that stuff in
your head, don't watch it.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think I think the the breakdown
with that is people really think like
it's not real. We know it's not real. We
know there's nobody walking around like
in a in a clown suit with his head
turning around like that. That's fake.
That's made up or whatever. But but
really the line between probably what is
real and not real is very blurred there.
>> Yeah. Well, and especially since the
brain has such a hard time
differentiating between reality and and
what is fiction from TV. I mean, I'm it
has to be messing with your head in so
many levels.
>> Yeah. Well, actually on the topic of uh
horror movies, a lot of it comes again
stems from uh brokenness in the home.
Mhm.
>> So as they as children are experience
experiencing the brokenness in the home,
uh the demon of suicide comes and they
gravitate to anything suicidal
>> or they just gravitate they just
naturally are attracted to anything that
uh is you know demonic or it feels like
torturous or something like that. So uh
you know they they so whilst we're
saying oh I don't know why they would
gravitate towards that it's it's because
of the brokenness in the home that
triggers that and then the demons start
to bring them towards that or simply
from what I've seen in a lot of families
uh especially in Asia both parents are
working so the kids are just home by
themselves and you know when they're by
themselves they experiment they open
doors they look at all sorts of programs
on television unsupervised eyes uh and
uh they watch it once they might have
been horrified the first time, but then
after that they've opened the door and
uh demons are coming in and they're
getting hooked.
>> Yeah, it's like a really crazy thing
because um you know if you're watching
things that make you scared and you get
addicted to that like scary feeling,
what's worse that you're watching it and
you don't get scared
>> like that's not fearful to you anymore.
And we know like you know with anything
it's you have to keep getting more and
more crazy to get that same sensation.
So,
>> I think if you desensitize that portion
of your life, I think then if a demon
does interact with you, it's not as
fearful.
>> I think that happens with some
pornography
>> victims, you know. Well, I don't know if
victim's the right word, but people that
do that, some of those keep going kind
of down a very dark path where it gets
more and more sinister or people are
being choked and
>> and Ted Bundy when when they did that
interview with him in the in the prison,
I mean, that was the one thing that he
said is like violent porn is what
desensitized me to someone's pain. And
it's like now you're you're finding
pleasure in giving somebody pain and it
just is super evil. My parents, my dad,
he would buy, you know, every few years
to buy a new TV because there were the
technology was improving. They now you
have flat screens, now you have thinner
TVs. So like he was like, "You can have
my old TV." I was in my bedroom
unsupervised
TV and computer at like 10. So yeah, I I
remember I was curious about the movie
Saw, which back in the time was like
huge, you know, and I would go to the
there was a store called Free Record
Store, which is not nothing free about
it, but you would go there and you get
the DVDs and the CDs and and I would see
the the the DVD covers of Saul and they
looked horrendous, but I was curious and
I remember watching it and I was like,
"This is disgusting. This is horrible."
And thanks to God, I never watched it
again. But but you can see how when
there's a broken family and there's no
family structure of people like working
together as a family like I know you
guys have said that when you watch
something you watch it try to watch it
together as a family right like you if
that doesn't exist then Satan comes in
and he will tempt the young minds to get
down these dark paths and that just
opens the door even more.
>> So I I just want to show some cartoons
that come from my new book. Uh it's
called His Victory is Ours. Um and uh
that came actually out of lectures I did
last year when I came to record with you
guys last year. And uh um so we've
written a book on that um because we've
gotten a lot of requests from all over
the world. Some people just want
something printed that they can refer to
and and it's really a lot of um stories,
a lot of testimonies of people that
we've helped, but also kind of a
methodology and and a process that you
can apply to uh both helping yourself
and helping somebody else that uh is
dealing with with demons. But I just
want to show two cartoons uh from that
to kind of get us understanding how
demons are actually attacking us. And if
you remember from the show that we did
last time, demons attack us in our
minds. Uh, and so the first place that
demons will uh come to start to try to
take control of uh our bodies is really
to start to insert um thoughts into our
minds. And so you can imagine when a
child is uh you know is very young and
he's seeing a lot of traumatic events
then the demons are you know they're
they they love that scenario and uh
they're coming to start to insert
thoughts into their minds. The first
cartoon deals with a husband and wife.
Uh, and I found uh equally well, the war
really starts with husband and wife
before it gets to the children. Uh, you
know, and so as soon as you get married,
demons are going to be there to try to
split you up. And so these thoughts that
we have as husband and wife about each
other, uh, you know, to and and often
the demons will come in and put
thoughts, I've married the wrong person.
uh we're not on the same page. Um my
wife doesn't understand me or my husband
doesn't understand me. Uh and these
thoughts we have to recognize as uh a
demon that is trying to split up the
family, right? And so in this cartoon
here, we see the demons attacking the
thoughts of the wife to say that she's
not good enough for her husband. Uh and
then he's attacking the husband to say
that, you know, he's uh married the
wrong person or she doesn't appreciate
him. uh and he continues to put more and
more of these thoughts and as they
embrace them it ends with the conclusion
let's divorce
>> which is really interesting because you
know when you get married let no man
split us under what God has brought
together right so it's like the very
union that God has has has put his stamp
on this is the way that it should be
should not be unraveled yes
>> so why would God
>> encourage you to divide that
>> that's right. Yeah. So, you know, when
we first get married, um you know,
especially if we're we're still fairly
young and uh you know, not really that
much fur yet, uh it's so easy for us to
embrace these thoughts, right? And in
society nowadays with these kind of um
wrong ideology of romance and uh you
know, it's all about meeting your
soulmate and uh feeling feelings of of
love, walking on cloud nine. When you're
not doing that anymore, then the demons
will hit us with a barrage of I've
married the wrong person or you know the
romance is over therefore we should
divorce right and we have to recognize
that there's a demon behind that.
>> The question comes up a lot when people
want to ask about like um romantic
movies and stuff like this and often the
picture that they're portraying is like
this person is no longer pleasing me
>> and the second you stop pleasing me then
I need to go over here. or they set up
the scenario with this girl is with some
abusive person here, but she really
should be with her best friend, but she
needs to get out of this relationship.
So, they they play with the audience's
mind to make the decision to leave that
person. And I'm sure if you watch a
bunch of those, that's going to play
into your relationship. Second this
person stops pleasing me, then we don't
need to be together.
>> And I I used to watch a bunch of
Nicholas Sparks movies. Nicholas Sparks
is the author of like the notebook and
uh um the last song you know and they
all have the same structure like you're
talking about of like you know um this
person right here like I'm with this
person but I'm supposed to be with this
person and I think it's true like when
you're set up like that and then the
demons come in and they speak all these
lies to you and you got to get your
boundaries up and and I would say also
reframe your thoughts you know like
using scripture to say what is the truth
about this person. Has God led so far?
And like is is this really the truth? Um
or is this a lie? And am I supposed to
reframe it and restructure it to what it
is the truth?
>> Look at what just the Ten Commandments
is showing us about the government of
God, right? It's about your relationship
with God and your relationship with man.
The entire thing is about a
relationship. So a demonic influence of
getting in the middle of that and
breaking that relationship is not what
the government of heaven is about.
That's right. Yeah. And if you look at
the book of Ephesians,
um you know, chapter one talks about how
Jesus is trying to unite heaven and
earth or reunite heaven and earth. And
then chapter 2 and chapter 3 is talking
about how he's trying to unite Jews and
Gentiles. And then chapter four is
talking about how he's trying to unite
the church as one body with one Lord,
one God, right? And then finally chapter
five he's uh Paul talks about how Jesus
really wants to unite the family. Right?
So if we if we relate all of that and
then finally in chapter six
>> before you can unite the family you got
to put on the armor of God. You got to
be prepared to fill yourself with the
word of God. And then that will help you
in your family which will then help the
church because church is made up of
multiple families and the smallest unit
of a church is the family. So if the
devil can destroy the family, he
destroys the church and then the if the
church is split apart then nations are
destroyed and if nations are destroyed
then you know it's uh God can't uh bring
us you know unite heaven and earth. So
that's been the problem.
>> I love how when you really kind of
distill down what what is this thing
called life? What is God? Right? He's
giving us so many examples of these
little like microcosmic versions where
it's like it explains this bigger thing,
but this bigger thing explains this
thing. And it's like you can see the
evidence. You can see the fingerprint of
God. And when it's torn apart, you can
see the fingerprint of the devil.
>> Yeah. So um you know what what's really
important also to understand for uh you
know young married couples is you know
in Genesis chapter 2 right at the end
when it says the two became one
>> is after Adam and Eve are are married
the first marriage everyone thinks oh if
I find the perfect soulmate and I'm
feeling very romantic and I'm walking on
cloud nine then automatically we'll run.
So, as soon as you have a bit of
conflict and disagreement or you're not
of the same mind, even about little
things like what to do with your
toothbrush in the bathroom, then
suddenly, oh, we are not one. But I
believe that when God said the two shall
become one, he's talking about a journey
of a lifetime, right? And and as we get
older uh you know in in our journey of
marriage and uh you know you have
children you realize that the most
important thing about marriage is
commitment.
>> Amen.
>> After before any romantic feelings or
after the feelings are gone what holds a
marriage together uh you know is the
commitment. And as we go longer and
longer and longer in your 10th year,
your 20th year, your 30th year, your
40th year, um that becoming one becomes
easier and easier. And really human
beings are that selfish and that
prideful that we need decades before we
can really humble ourselves to well many
of us I shouldn't say that for everyone
but many of us need that decades of
commitment before feeling to then get to
the point oh I think I've finally
starting to understand my wife a little
bit.
>> I told my wife she's stuck with me. I
know there's no marriage in giving a
marriage in heaven, but that's that's
that's I said I'm going to ask for an
apartment right next door to you then.
>> Yeah. So, you know, the the devil is on
all out and I believe as I have, you
know, counseledled a lot more uh since
we last spoken. Um I I believe that uh
the devil is really attacking the family
because if he can destroy husband and
wife and the institution of marriage,
the commitment to marriage, then uh
there are devastating effects to the
children.
>> So I just want to show the next cartoon
and this is a home where you have uh
both husband and wife now are arguing.
uh they're using the word divorce um and
the child is having it's having a
devastating effect on the child. And who
comes to the child? The demon will come
to the child as they're seeing and
experiencing this trauma. Uh the demon
will start to say things like it's all
my fault.
>> Right? And then he'll follow it up with
other thoughts like I'm worthless. Um
you know if uh I I my parents are
fighting because of me. Uh and then
eventually that concludes in I want to
die,
>> right? And and as the fighting
intensifies
um those thoughts of I want to die, uh
you know, the the demons start to put
imaginations in our mind of perhaps
going to the kitchen, picking up a knife
to cut myself, right? And the first time
that happens though the the child is
horrified um because you know they never
thought of something like that before
and they ignore it. But as the fighting
continues and the parents are not
realizing the devastating effect it has
on the child then the thought you know
the imagination keeps coming back. Pick
up the knife. Pick up the knife. Pick up
the knife. And you know one day they
actually go to the kitchen and pick up
the knife and they might put it at their
wrist but then they throw it back. But
then as the int the fighting continues
over months or years, they finally go
and pick up the knife and cut
themselves, right? And and I've seen uh
many children who parents are coming to
me and they're like, I don't know why my
my child is cutting herself. She's never
done this before. Um but usually the
root of the problem is fighting in the
home or brokenness or, you know,
divorce. uh you know as soon as kids
hear their parents talking about divorce
there's great fear and uh um uh trauma
and eventually self-hatred that you know
comes in.
>> Yeah. I think it's I think it's it's
it's really interesting to look at like
in your cartoon the the final step like
you said is it comes down to the child
wanting to commit suicide
>> but it started at some point layers
above that with how do the parents see
romance love how do they relate to each
other and so I'm just thinking what kind
of things cause those parents to maybe
have those misunderstandings It's like
where does it start? I'm thinking one of
the things like what we do with this
media, you know, like you were talking
about like the movies you watch, the
books you read, the music led into the
house, not just the portrayal of
marriage in those things and romance,
but also just certain movies and music
allowing the demons into the home, but
how do you see that like where does the
what like you talk about the bottom of
it, but what what's at the top of this?
>> Yeah. So, let me talk about my my
marriage. Mhm.
>> And uh you know this is really kind of
these cartoons kind of reflect a lot of
what happened in my marriage and and for
the first 10 years of our marriage uh
you know I constantly had that thought
put into my mind and I didn't know
anything about demons back then but
constantly the thought would just come
into my mind all of a sudden I married
the wrong woman. M
>> um and the thought that the demons were
connecting or the imagination uh and the
scenes that the demons were connecting
into my mind was that
and uh was because my wife would laugh
at me openly,
>> right? And so it was common for her
because my wife is an extrovert. I'm an
introvert,
>> right? And and often in marriage I have
observed God brings together opposites.
uh not because he enjoys this kind of
conflict and clashing, but we were
supposed to complete each other. And if
we're exactly the same, there's not much
to complete, but you know, if we're
different, then the journey of a
lifetime actually could be
>> a lot of fun
>> as we try to figure out how to fit
together. Or it could be very um you
know damaging, jarring um because we
keep headbutting rather than realizing
well if we just kind of move the fingers
a little bit right to fit together we we
could actually make this work.
>> Um but the demons were putting in my
mind that my wife uh didn't respect me
because she laughed at me openly and of
course she would because she's an
extrovert and she's a practical joker
and she loves to joke, right? But what
the demons were connecting what she was
doing back to was what my mother had
done to me in childhood. Uh and remember
she uh you know if you remember my story
um she had grown up uh with a a very
unholy temper as well. And she struggled
with that temper and and controlling
herself. And so there would be massive
outbursts from her when we were
children. And me being a more
introverted person in the beginning of
my life, uh you know, it would be very
uh traumatic for me if my mom had an
outburst. And so what the demons were
doing was connecting my childhood trauma
to what my wife was doing, which
absolutely has no connection whatsoever.
But if you entertain these thoughts and
you allow them to come in and you're not
combating them and you're not uh you
know coming together to worship God
together as a husband and wife then
these lies perpetuate. Uh and so what
the demons are masters at doing
especially in families and for husband
and wife is connecting our childhood
traumas uh into the marriage. And so
suddenly we're interpreting anything our
spouse does as connected back to the
trauma that we did and we're just losing
our temper and and many times my wife
would be like why are you upset you know
I was just laughing but for me there was
this whole you know false um scene movie
that was being played in my mind that
was kind of you know there was the
iceberg at the top and then there was
everything underneath that my wife was
not seeing and I was not communicating,
but it was just upsetting me, right? And
so, one of the things I share as I do
marriage counseling with young married
couples is
>> understand each other's trauma,
understand the childhood trauma that you
face because most likely the demons are
going to use that to separate you.
>> Yeah, you got to deal with it. I know
I've been I've had to deal with that for
>> many years. And even seems like now I'm
I'm still like discovering reasons of
why I am the way I am.
>> You know, it's like, oh, that's that's
why. But you have you have to deal with
it. If you don't deal with it, it eats
your life.
>> So, it's easy sometimes, like,
especially if you misunderstand the
person or you know, you don't recognize
that you misunderstand them or you're
upset to just kind of like mle over in
your head.
>> But I think that's when the demons can
use it. But then when you communicate it
and you have it in the open, it's almost
like you break that power that they have
over it because now you're vulnerable
before each other and you can pray over
it together.
>> And I also think it's a good reason why
why God told Adam and Eve to work
together, right? When you're separate,
you could they that you basically can
come to you and influence you to do all
sorts of random stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> So I think like that to to have the
strength of that unit together, even if
you're struggling something to come to
your spouse and say, "Look, I'm I'm
really battling this in my mind." And
often we go to the far extreme of it
wasn't really probably like that and and
it can be recorrected pretty quickly. Um
but without a conversation it just fers
and causes a wound.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So advice uh another advice
I give to young married couples as well
is um come together once a week at least
>> and actually sit down and say to one
another what are the lies that the
demons have been telling you about me?
>> Right? and and actually recognize the
fact that uh we are being lied to uh on
a daily basis and the demons are always
going to try to insert all sorts of lies
just you know it's almost like an
experiment to them I I feel like and
they're trying to see which ones we're
going to react to uh and embrace right
and if we don't communicate if we just
>> allow them to keep inserting thoughts
into our minds and we keep embracing it
and then we don't communicate to clarify
those thoughts and and literally point
out, hey, there have been lies. I'm sure
there have been lies this week. So, you
know what? What's what's been making
what's been upsetting you about what
I've been doing? Uh, and then if you
align that, then you can cut out all the
lies.
>> Yeah. So, it's it's important. Uh, and
so when is the good time to do that?
Morning and evening worship as a family.
So, even as a couple, we should be
coming together to do morning and
evening worship. And if we had done that
and then filling oursel with truth and
then talking about the lies that have
been put in our minds that would really
help to clear up a lot of this.
>> Yeah. And so that's that's the solution.
Um there's just one more diagram I I
really wanted to show. So um this is
also a recap from the last time as well
but um you know with some graphics. So
really where are negative thoughts
coming from? It's coming from demons.
Why do why are ne some negative thoughts
more powerful in certain individuals
than others? It's because we've opened
doors um you know and uh we talked last
time about the different types of open
doors that we can have. Um and you know
music uh movies um but also sins the
sins that we've committed that we
haven't confessed. occult type items.
You know, all of these things play a
part in uh you know, actually opening
that door and and allowing demons to
have more effect on us. Uh and then as
those thoughts have such a powerful
effect on us as we embrace it, then the
demons are able to do all sorts of
things like connected to earlier
childhood and make that so real to us
that we start believing that our wife is
the one causing the same trauma that we
experienced when we were younger. uh you
know and then that uh that just grows
into a mountain uh and the way to deal
with that is I need to neutralize the
negative thoughts or destroy the
negative thoughts or replace them with
positive thoughts from God. Right? And
that's why it's so important for us to
immerse ourselves in the word of God
whether that's by singing it, reading
it, teaching it, preaching it, hearing
it. Um you know we the word of God if we
keep immersing ourselves in the word of
God uh then that becomes automatic as
opposed to automatically defaulting to
depressive thoughts or negative thoughts
about our wife. Yeah. So that's the way
to neutralize. I was going to say going
back to your situation, that's one thing
I was going to say is
if your identity was rooted in Christ,
then it wouldn't have affected you the
same way when your wife laughed out loud
in public because you would be okay with
you and God and who you are. And so it
wouldn't have had that negative effect
on you the same way.
>> Possibly. Um I I would like to maybe put
it this way. Um the reason why the
demons were able to make that connection
was because I hadn't fully reconciled
with my mom.
>> Um so whilst I was studying the Bible uh
and I'm I'm in ministry, I'm you know
involved uh in in yeah and I'm studying
God's word but there was an open door of
I hadn't reconciled. I hadn't forgiven
my mom,
>> right? And I was still holding on to
things that you know that was um you
know that it was her fault right and
then they connected it because you know
boys marry their mothers and then ladies
marry their fathers. So if the if if
Satan is able to destroy that you know
childhood relationship with you know for
boys with their mothers then when they
marry their wives uh they're going to
reconnect all of that. Yeah. So yes,
it's important definitely to have that
relationship with Jesus, but I I guess
you know what what that uh what that
should have led me to is really
reconciling uh you know with uh with my
mom. Uh and so that you know is another
area actually of uh how demons are able
to get to children is this unforgiveness
that we grow up with. Uh, you know, you
don't even have to have the most broken
home, but a lot of us grow up dealing
with unforgiveness with our parents,
with one or the other parent.
>> Um, you know, or even siblings. Uh, and
so unforgiveness is one of those
invisible sins that really affect us.
>> Yeah. I remember last time I think we
talked a little bit about this area of
unforgiveness. I mean, think about it.
You're abused as a child or something.
You're going to, you know, have
unforgiveness towards the males or
whatever. And it it can cause all kinds
of different things.
>> Um I know in you know who's who's grown
up in a family that hasn't gotten hurt,
right? We've all had our experiences and
and the times that I feel that I was
closest to my parents were were times
that I didn't wait for them to come and
apologize, but it was just like I myself
was able to say I forgive for what
happened here and let's move on. And
then it's like all like a weight just
gets lifted off your shoulders. So
>> yeah, unforgiveness, if you have any of
that in your life, here is the number
one, I think, stronghold that the demons
work through and they can penetrate into
the circles of your family.
>> That's right. Yeah. You know, so again,
that's connected back to brokenness,
abuse, uh arguing in the home, but you
can still overcome that if the parents,
you know, create an atmosphere of openly
forgiving one another,
>> right? So it's so important as parents
uh if we go back to the previous cartoon
it's it's so important for both husband
and wife to openly
um you know reconcile in front of their
children and apologize to each other and
then apologize to the children
>> because many times parents argue and
they think well it's between my wife and
I it's nothing to do with the kids so I
don't have to apologize to the kids but
when you understand what the demons are
feeding to the kids in terms of negative
thoughts and that it could lead to
suicide side.
>> Um, you know, what is uh apologizing to
them as well? That's that's nothing,
right? And so creating that atmosphere
of openly reconciling, openly forgiving
one another and asking for forgiveness
from your children when they see you
fight, um, you know, it's it's so it's
so important.
>> Yeah. So, those are one of the solutions
as well. I want to talk a little bit
about um the Bible
>> and how
uh you know there's two examples in the
Bible where parents brought their came
to Jesus about their children.
>> Um you know there's a example of the
Canaanite woman
>> who comes to Jesus and he ignores her
and then he insults her in a way and
humiliates her. Um, you know, but all of
that was to show really the mentality of
his disciples and the Jews, but she's
coming to Jesus and begging him to heal
her demon-possessed child, right? And uh
and and I think a lesson that we can
learn from there is that the faith, her
faith and her willingness to go through
anything for her child um you know
eventually God answered that prayer and
it was and and Jesus commends her for
having great faith. Mhm.
>> Uh and so, you know, if our children at
least, you know, if they're young
enough, and I would like to I'm thinking
that this child was probably a lot who
wasn't in the late teens or anything,
but you know, was at an age where the
parents still was able to take care of
them, manage them, you know, and and the
the mother really wanted freedom for her
daughter because of her great faith.
Jesus was able to heal her. M that was
always such a strange strange way that
he reacted to it. But you know Yeah. I I
I like that thought that you know he was
just really like displaying what would
have been the common mindset there.
>> Yes.
>> But then also playing that out.
>> Yeah. So so I think another important
lesson here is that uh really the faith
of the parents can save our children.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. If we turn around our lives and
we go to God and we plead with him on
behalf of our children. Um I believe God
always wants to answer the prayer of uh
the parents
>> even when they're older. But of course
uh you know it's as they get older
they're their own person and you know
they have a lot more say in their
decision. Uh the other example I'd like
to talk about is um the father who
brings
uh the the son uh where to the nine
disciples and they're not able to cast
out the demon from his son and then
Jesus comes down from the mount of
transfiguration and uh Jesus is able to
do it. Uh but before he does that again
he says to the father if you believe all
things are possible
>> right and then the father
you know uh shares or screams out the
the famous words I believe help thou my
unbelief
>> uh and so you know the the faith of the
parents are so important in deliverance
for the children as well. So, and many
times I find when we're counseling,
>> it's actually the parents who need the
counseling more than the child. Uh, and
it's what the parents are doing more
than what the children are doing. There
there's something that the children is
doing, but uh the parents and how
they're behaving and their lack of faith
or, you know, their lack of relationship
with Jesus and all the open doors
they're opening is probably more
damaging to the child than what the
child is doing.
>> Yeah. Because children really mimic the
the parents. Yeah. You know, like like
as a parent, if you're a parent that
cusses all the time, your child's going
to learn cuss words and he's going to
use it.
>> Yeah.
>> But if you're a parent that sing
scripture songs, your child's going to
get in the habit of scripture songs. So,
I can see that. Um, you know, it it it
it
really shows that the need for Christ to
be in the home and for us to search our
hearts and just ask the Lord like, "Show
me, Lord, what is it that I need to
change and help me to change so that I
can be fully surrendered to you?" And we
have a family that walks in in your
ways. And he can help all of us because
none of us are perfect at that. You
know, none of us here at the table are
are trying to look like saints who are
preaching to uh to a bunch of
unbelievers. We are all um in need of
Jesus. Yeah.
>> But he can help all of us.
>> There's generational sins that you know
maybe the parents struggled with or
dealt with that get passed on down the
road. So I think it's like at at least a
comforting feeling as a parent that you
know I can go to God and plead for
whatever problems that have existed in
my past not to be passed forward to my
children or you know let let my faith
help in this situation as well. And you
know, it's not just like God's like,
"Well, you're sorry. There's nothing I
can do for you." It's it's as a parent,
if you have that type of of humility,
like like I'd be willing to lay it out
on the table because I know my kids are
struggling and I'm probably the one that
brought that in. Um I think that's a
nice like um thing that we need to do.
>> Scotty, you brought up generational
sins. David, could you explain a little
bit about what that is and how it
affects the a family? Yeah. So,
generational sins is where somebody, you
know, in great-grandparents,
grandparents, or even parents, uh, have
made a pact with the devil.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh, and that could be in the form of
witchcraft. It could be in the form of
Satanism. Um, it could even be in the
form of secret societies. And if they've
been high up, uh, you know, and involved
in Luciferian type activities, then the
demons are coming after future
generations. So, uh I think in my last
uh one of my previous um you know times
that I've been here, I talked about my
wife's testimony and her grandmother was
a witch doctor.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh and so that opened the doors for
demons to really go after her uh in a in
a stronger way. Uh and similarly uh you
know along that uh line of thought um
bringing our kids to witch doctors uh
also has a huge and powerful impact uh
you know and uh there is a girl that we
have helped who came to us in 2021. We
started helping her and her parents have
brought her to a witch doctor when she
was five years old and from the or
younger than that and ever since the age
of four or five she had demon friends
that would always that grew up with her.
>> Wow.
>> Uh and uh and then when she got to high
school or maybe even a little bit before
that they turned on her
>> you know they started to torture her.
they had started to uh attack her um you
know and uh she tried to commit suicide
in high school then in university uh and
then when they kicked her out of
university um you know once more at home
and that's when we came into contact
with her. But you know through that
occult connection
um just like my wife with you know her
grandmother being a witch um there was
so many demons that she had to deal with
and it's taken us years you know three
three or four years to really get to the
point where she has had freedom. Um but
they're always hanging around and
they're always trying to come back in
and it's so familiar. so natural for her
to let them back in that uh you know
she's it's taken her years to build that
um that strength and last year in
December uh you know I was doing a
deliverance together with her and what
we discovered what the Holy Spirit had
led us to was that when one of the times
when she was possessed the demons had
led her into a forest and she had a
wedding ceremony with Lucifer. Wow.
>> So, she had an invisible ring on her
ring finger
>> that she was always touching, but she
didn't realize that that's what it was.
>> Uh, and the Holy Spirit convicted her to
ask God to destroy that ring.
>> Uh, and you know, once God destroyed
that ring, then the demons came out.
>> I mean, it's crazy that like, have you
guys ever seen things like the movie If
Imaginary Friend?
>> Yeah. Well, I haven't seen the movie.
I've seen the trailer.
[Music]
Hi. Well, lookie lookie. She is the
perfect fit. I promise. Did she even see
you? She was about to.
What are you doing? Don't do this.
No. No. No.
Hi.
>> In our day and age, um there was a
couple like um something about like
Freddy something or other. I don't even
remember the names of them, but they
were all like imaginary friends. Like
this has been a theme that I've seen
movies over and over. Like they're kind
of teetering on this idea that there's
these beastly things that the kids see
that no one else does. and it tells them
how to live their life or whatever like
things. Um that's very real.
>> It is.
>> I very real. And and I think um when we
talked to you and and a few of the
others that that were talking about some
of these experiences, I mean the things
that people have seen, I would just
scare me to never sleep again, you know,
and and it's very real that people
experience these kind of things. And um
I praise God that you're you're you're
you know opening your mouth about it and
you're being able to help some people
with it because Yeah. It's like this
isn't a common thing that people talk
about, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So yeah, we have to be wary if our
if our child tells us they have
imaginary friends. Um that is not a good
thing.
>> And it's not a cute thing either. at
some point that's going to turn into
possession and uh you know it's it's it
could potentially you know take their
life.
>> Mhm.
>> So so what's a generational sin that
could has happen more in the western
society? I mean I know you mentioned
secret societies but I guess maybe like
like you mentioned like occult practices
or anything like that. I new age
spiritualism. So, funnily enough, you
know, from the last time the show that I
was on the show and it went out, uh, the
people that have reached out to me the
most to talk about witchcraft is
actually from America.
>> So, it's a lot more prevalent than
Americans think that that it exists, you
know, and and people have reached out
saying,
>> uh, you know, either witches have been
giving them gifts and they didn't
realize and
>> wait, like actual witches.
>> Yes. they just came up to them or
>> uh they they're neighbors
>> what
>> and you know in birthday parties or
giving them just gifts to their children
and their daughter is possessed. I can
remember when I worked in television um
there was a lot of people that would
pass around crystals
>> and that they were had some kind of
thing in the you would write your I
don't even remember what the reasons
were but everybody on the set started
wearing these crystals and there was one
guy that like you just knew if you know
go get a necklace from this guy and
it'll align whatever
>> and and you know I growing up in
Christianity never believed that kind of
stuff but I always thought it was kind
of silly not necessarily recognizing
that that's a real
>> witchcraft object, you know, and and
yeah, we have so many things in the
movies and I think Hollywood has done a
disservice to the western culture by
>> sort of teetering on this. It's not
really real. So, they can dismiss it
that this doesn't happen, but it is
these are very real things. And many
people in in America are very interested
in witchcraft. I mean, go to your local
Walmart and look at the book section,
you know.
>> Yeah.
>> There's a lot of witchcraft stuff in
there.
>> Yeah.
>> Or like you said, the crystals like I
don't know where I was. It was somewhere
somewhere in the Chattanooga area. Oh,
it was uh Ruby Falls, you know, the the
famous waterfall, the Yeah, tourist
trap. But anyway, but I mean, I went
into the shop and there was tons of
crystals because they dug it from
underground. But then immediately I'm
thinking like, oh, those are nice
crystals that God made, but other people
associate them with like, oh, they have
healing powers and all these kind of
things. And so, it's literally
everywhere. It's literally at a tourist
attraction waterfall and then it's like,
go buy your crystals for your healing,
you know? So I can I see your point like
it's literally we're surrounded by it.
>> It is. Yeah. And I remember I was in St.
St. Louis recently and I walked into a
uh candy shop and in the candy shop
there was a uh a book of spells.
>> Wow.
>> As like part of the candy.
>> Wow. That you could buy. And you would
get a free book of spells if you bought
that particular candy.
>> Yeah. I remember one time I went to
Walmart with Mikey and we were looking
through the the kids toy section and it
was nonstop just witchcraft. They had
all these little like um dolls that you
could learn how to do spells and it was
all this candycoated mix this together
and cast a a love spell on somebody or
whatever. And it's like that's straight
witchcraft.
>> Well, I grew up not being a Christian
and so we read the majority of the Harry
Potter books. We got them from the
library and we I saw a bunch of the
movies and I went home trying to cast
spells because of the books.
>> So yeah, like it's just so entrenched in
our society. But again, um like you're
saying, David, we need to keep our eyes
on Jesus.
>> And while the books are fiction, that it
mentions like real words that are used
in
>> incantations and spells and it mentions
real places. And
>> the names in Harry Potter, I I think are
actual real names of demons.
>> Wow. So you have to be careful.
>> Yeah. So I guess in closing I just
wanted to mention some solutions and
things that we need to put in practice
in the home to protect us.
>> Mhm.
>> Um the first one is having family
worship consistently.
uh and if both parents there's something
about family worship that if we make it
a principle and not by feeling only when
we're on good terms I'm going to do
family worship but if both husband and
wife can agree that no matter how we're
feeling we're going to have family
worship somehow having family worship
together and hearing truth from God
kind of pacifies our hearts and calms us
down even to the point where we want to
do reconciliation. So it's so important
for us to and actually that is one of
the most simple uh but profound
solutions that God has given to us which
is morning and evening worship with the
family. Um and it would be good if the
husband can lead that in the home as the
priest but you know if that's not
possible then mother can also lead that
uh and uh and that becomes the healing
balm for the home individually we should
also be studying the word of god um and
uh to deal with this problem of the
influences whether it's movies or music
and you know I really appreciate the
ministry that you guys are doing and
exposing all that um but it's so
deceptive now and you know it's so
prevalent and it's so hard to really
determine which one is a good movie and
which one's a bad movie that or or which
one is good music or bad music. So I
really recommend singing scripture in
the home especially for the kids at a
young age and you know they may not
understand it but somehow it's so easy
to memorize. It's so much easier for
kids to memorize the Bible just by
singing it. You know, it's just like how
we used to r sing sing uh what's that
that Sesame Street,
>> right? Everyone grew up just singing
Sesame Street. And even when you're
older, you kind of have it in the in in
that song in your head. Wouldn't it be
great if as our kids get older, that
song that's still in their head is not
Sesame Street, um but different
scriptures of uh of the Bible, right?
And that's the other way to protect our
child's mind. So we may not know um you
know when the demons are attacking them
and how they're attacking them. But if
we start at a young age um to sing
scripture songs in our family worship
immediately subconsciously our kids are
just hiding the word of God in their
hearts and that has a that that
definitely is a huge way that God can
protect our kids. Mhm.
>> I want to add as well where you talk
about family worship for a for the
married couple to have worship together
as well. And I know sometimes that's
really difficult when you have kids and
I don't have kids yet, but I know of
people that have small kids and it's
very challenging just for them to have
worship by themselves, but um
>> you know the there's some studies that
have been done that show that when uh a
married couple prays together every day,
I think that it lowers the divorce rate
by like 50% or something like that. So
you can see that you know God wants that
unity to be connected in spiritually uh
physically emotionally in all aspects.
>> Definitely.
>> And a good way to get your kids involved
too um is have them play an instrument.
>> And when you come together as a family
you're playing something together and
you're you know I think that's was that
the neat thing about music is is you
really are making these different sounds
fit together. I mean that's why I think
God loves music. Um, you know, the
devil's taken that and he's robbed it.
He's added all these dissident and
offset sounds and things that don't
really blend together and they're kind
of off, but God's music is very like
harmonious and and and works together.
So, just in a simple way, that's a great
way to to just settle the the whatever
differences we've had in the day. Let's
sing, let's praise God. And I I've
definitely experienced that in our own
home that that is makes a big
difference. And the last thing that I
find uh is really important nowadays
uh especially so many children are
coming from broken homes or have
experienced brokenness in one way or
another. Uh I find that um brokenness
makes it really hard for us to trust
God.
>> And a lot of I've started to realize
more and more as I've done counseling uh
you know for spiritual warfare that it's
hard to deliver. It's hard for God to
deliver somebody who doesn't trust them.
>> Uh, you know, so they might be saying,
"I want to be delivered. I want to be
saved." But then the next moment they're
like, "Ah, I don't know if God really
loves me."
>> Um, or, you know, I I think where I'm
at, I'm too far gone for God to to
really help me. And and that kind of
neutralizes unbelief neutralizes faith.
Mhm.
>> Um, you know, and and that prevents God
because then the demon of unbelief comes
along and says, "God, you can't help
this person because they they're holding
on to me more than they're really
wanting to hold on to you."
>> Uh, and so what I've I've started to do
recently is as part of counseling for
somebody that's going that's wanting to
be free from the devil,
>> I'm counseling them to really study the
love of God.
>> Amen. uh in order for us to heal from
our pro our broken relationships
>> whether that's from our father, our
mother, um you know, or anything else
that happened to us in childhood.
>> It's the love of God that's going to
heal.
>> Yeah. And so the greatest place for us
to experience the love of God is what
the Bible calls the power of the cross.
M
>> and I'm coming to realize the power of
the cross is really repairing all that
traumatic imaginations that we have in
our mind that the demons are just
throwing in there all the time. Uh we
can heal that by experiencing and fully
understanding the love of God at the
cross.
>> What true love would do is as that
person is nailing those hands to the
cross, Jesus is praying for him.
>> Yep. Lord, you know, don't hold this
against them. They don't know what
they're doing, you know. And that right
there is is a demonstration of what
godly love looks like. Even in the face
of somebody harming you, you're you're
you're wanting to still save them.
>> Yeah. And it also comes from the Bible
text um where um I believe is it in
first John uh we love him because he
first loved us.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And so it's really hard for us to
love God and trust God just
intellectually and theoretically just
because the Bible says so.
>> Mhm.
>> Until we really understand how God loved
us.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. And so what I'm trying what I'm
doing for a lot of people that
experienced so much brokenness is I'm
counseling them, you know, really study
deeply what happened at the cross until
you can feel it, until you can visualize
it, until you can touch it, taste it,
see it, right? Um and that's when you
know that you really are beginning to
understand the love of God. And and
there's a a book that I love so much um
that really helps to get us to that
deeper level and it's the book Desire of
Ages.
>> Beautiful.
>> Uh and I and I you know I I I tell
people who are struggling with trusting
God. So anybody who comes to me and says
I had abuse in my childhood naturally uh
defaulting to you have a problem with
trusting God.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. That's that's the purpose of the
abuse that God has that Satan has has
introduced to us in our life. And so I
tell them go to read the chapters on
Gethsemane to the chapters on it is
finished. I think it's about five
chapters. And take it and read it slowly
and repetitively. So take the first
chapter, read it 10 times, right? Until
you can imagine each scene. And somehow
that starts to unlock in their mind how
much God loves them. And when they
understand how much God loves them, then
they can begin to trust God and and
really um go on that journey to be free.
>> Yeah. And what I like about that book is
that it's basically a commentary on the
gospels. So you read through the Gospels
with uh a good commentary on it. So I
really value and appreciate that that
book very much. Yeah.
>> David, thank you so much for coming in
sharing your enlightening
book with us. Tell us where we can get
this book. Uh we've actually created a
website um on the title of the book. So
his victory is ours.org.
>> Um you can go that go there and uh I
think we'll put that in the link as well
and uh you know you'll be able to click
on that and get the book um and uh we'll
be putting that on Amazon so you can
order that on Amazon easily everywhere.
>> Awesome. And also, if somebody wants to
get a hold of you to either learn more
or they have something that they would
like to try and and and get some help
with, how can they contact you?
>> Uh, I'll leave you with uh my email,
davidaeb.org,
davidaoi.org.
And uh feel free to email me and uh I'll
be happy to answer questions.
>> Awesome. Thanks for coming by.
>> Thank you. If you like this video, like,
subscribe,
>> and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos.
>> And drop a comment below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
>> Say that again. No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]